talk about certifying calling over
non-negativity by a hyperbolic
optimization okay thank you very much
Bren for the introduction and the
organizers for inviting me to be here
it's a real pleasure to be here
it's wonderful to see some people I know
but also many people I don't know and I
look forward to meeting you throughout
the workshop
let's just talk about so at some level
I'm interested in the basic problem of
deciding whether a multivariate with
real coefficients is no negative the
basic underlying question in the back of
our minds for the story and what's the
the main idea I want to sort of put
forward in this talk is one approach for
trying to come up with certificates of
non negativity of a multivariate
polynomial but somehow I can search for
them by a hyperbolic optimization by a
solving or hyperbolic optimization sort
of present a one approach to finding
this kind of tractable certificate
sufficient conditions for non negative
that's that's the main you know thrust
of the talk there's going to be kind of
three parts for the talk the first part
I'm going to say what are hyperbolic
polynomials and hyperbolic optimization
and so on to make sure it's the first
talk of the workshops I think it's a
good opportunity to just say these
things then I'm going to move towards
how do I get somehow non-negative
polynomials from hyperbola City in one
natural way to do that and then the last
part of the middle to end of the talk
will be about sort of understanding a
bit about the relationship between these
hyperbolic certificates of non
negativity and sums of squares which is
a kind of absolute familiar more well
studied way of certifying non negativity
of multi very pointer meals in some kind
of tractable way by a convex
optimization let's start with hyperbolic
polynomials so we'll say that our
polynomial is homogeneous of degree D
and n variable so I try to stick to the
D fat
enfin number of variables is hyperbolic
with respect to some direction in orange
if when I evaluate the polynomial in
that direction its positive negative is
also okay just not zero okay let's say
positive that's one thing and more
importantly perhaps is that no matter
where I start in my space if I look at
my polynomial along the line defined by
this direction okay it has all real
roots this is the basic definition and
okay so here's an example of somebody
who is hyperbolic with respect to say
the vertical direction if I saw it
anywhere I go on a lion I hit this
surface where the poem you're banished
is exactly twice counting multiplicity
and this is an example of a situation
where I'm not hyper bike because if I
hit this surface only twice I only have
two real roots just a quick comment that
although I'm not going to make a lot of
use of this in the talk and the
definition here I'm saying this needs to
happen for all X in the space it's
pretty easy to see that it's fine to
restrict to some for example codimension
one subspace that doesn't contain your
distinguish direction so many of the
statements I'll have polynomials in n
variables you can potentially restrict
them to be polynomials and n minus 1
variables by this kind of idea and using
this kind of idea and things will still
be true okay so these are hyperbolic
polynomials the reason from an
optimization perspective I think these
are interesting is that there's a
natural convex object associated with a
hyperbolic polynomial and that is what
we call so I can define a cone by taking
all the points in RN so that when I look
at this characteristic polynomial type
object okay I look at the roots along
this line I've changed the minus signs
just for convenience here that all of
these real roots are non-negative
all the time you'll have to find out
real roots along this line I can ask
them the points where all of these roots
are negative this defines a cone and you
know the foundational result in this
area is that this is a convex cone
closed convex cone result that dates
from the PD of a teacher activities so
just to look at our exact one of our
examples if I take this particular
polynomial insisting the roots are non
negatives will give me this solid ice
cream cone on the rinse cone or
second-order cone very familiar
optimization what's the meaning of this
cone I mean as I defined it here it's
not I mean I can take this picture and I
get the convex cone but I don't know
what my definition does not probably
make sense yeah okay so this is just a
do to have a fixed concrete example in
mind so once I have a nice way to
construct a convex cone optimizer I
think about then defining a class of
optimization problems family of
optimization problems where I consider
optimizing a linear cost function
subject to some affine constraints and
this conic constraint nice family of
convex optimization problems looks kind
of mundane when presented like this but
there's lots of special cases of this
problem which turned out to be very
interesting okay linear programming is
very interesting right take a particular
choice of polynomial where I'm a high
publicity cone this is a non negative
orphaned second-order Cohen programming
at second and semi definite programming
come up with different examples of
respectable hyperbolic polynomial
hyperbola speaker okay so I guess one
thing that's very much not obvious that
we've learned over the years very much
not obvious which optimization problems
I can and cannot rewrite somehow in some
equivalently in this form
in the case of hyperbolic programming
sort of this class of problems is of
particular interest because of its fact
that if you take the negative log of
this polynomial this gives me a nice
barrier function on this code
whole theory of interior point methods
then means that I can from this
essentially extract efficient algorithms
to solve this classification so we're
going to hear a bit more about the
algorithmic side later today I believe
see more about concrete algorithms from
its class of problems or at least
there's a little caveat I'll get
efficient algorithms if I can evaluate P
ok so it's depends on how this
polynomial is presented to you
relatively easy to come up with
hyperbolic polynomials that are not easy
to actually evaluate some degree and
some number of variables that are
reasonable but it's quite difficult to
evaluate when HD bit careful and also
suggests this is you know quite a big
problem class perhaps because you have
these kinds of so that's my quick intro
to hyperbolic polynomials this
corresponding convex object the high
publicity cone and now this class of
optimization problems
let's now talk a little bit about
testing high publicity so you give me
homogeneous polynomial in n variables of
degree D okay I want to decide is it
hyperbolic or not okay with respect to
some direction I'm going to come back to
this a little later in the talk this
idea but I'm also it's going to lead
into our way of producing you know
non-negative pointer meals naturally
from hyperbolic volume so that's that's
kind of the motivation for the scales so
there's many different ways to test if I
have a ballistic
hypervelocity one way and the way I'm
gonna sort of the threat I'm gonna
follow in this talk is by looking at by
taking by polynomial and here I've got
this lambda sine lambda sub L of X these
are going to be the eigenvalues with
respect to this polynomial so the real
roots of my hyperbolic polynomial on the
Z direction and I can build this matrix
of power sons essentially it's Hank or
matrix of power sons ok the minus signs
are not super important but they're for
convenience for what I'm doing and
there's a result that I mean is in this
paper of Timnath on your permanent home
but it's classical result have not yet
exactly is that P as hyperbolic with
respect to e if and only if this matrix
is PST for all X ok so this is a matrix
with it's not obvious from this
description but with polynomial entries
the power sums I can relate to the
coefficients of the polynomial
polynomial entries and so this matrix of
polynomial entries if it's PSD for all X
then I'll be hyperbolic and converse
where do you see that if I you know if I
know for some reason my polynomial is
hyperbolic with respect to some
direction I get some non-negative
polynomials so for example I could look
at the diagonal entries here but I can
evaluate this this quadratic form
somewhere in or get some non-negative
Portage's
I want to just and some of the reason
why this is true if you haven't seen it
before is that this in the case where
you have this is really the vandermonde
matrix times its transpose well one way
or the other and if all the roots are
real that will be a nice cholesky
factorization they give you obviously so
I want to just know write down one way
to one way to produce this object okay
that will generalize in the next slide
and will give us more non negative
polynomials from our hyperbolic point
what's the alternative view one view of
this I can think about a rational
function so I think of it this is a
univariate rational function in T so
when I take the derivative of my
polynomial so I'm using this notation D
sub e for the directional derivative in
the e direction but this is really just
the derivative of this polynomial in T
divided by my polynomial I write it out
as a Laurent series like this and I look
at the coefficients and I build the
Hankel matrix out of these coefficients
and I get exactly this angle matrix out
here because what's gonna happen on the
next slide is we're going to do
something like this in a tiny bit more
generality so that was a nice kind of
gave us a way to connect hyper being
hyperbolic to kind of a certain
polynomial matrix being PSD for all X
what we got now C is a kind of very
similar type statement that describes
the hyperbola Citigo so what we're gonna
do is something very similar at least to
define this this object so I'm going to
define a polynomial matrix it's a Hankel
matrix polynomial at X it's going to be
linear in this other variable U and
we're going to so tell you how to define
it appear from this rational expansion
one
so I'm going to do is take the
derivative the directional derivative of
my polynomial not in the e direction but
just in the direction you okay and you
can be whatever you like your favorite
you in are in I think it's derivative
over this polynomial think of it's a
rational function of T I can do the same
kind of expansion and look at these
coefficients okay they're all going to
be linear in U because this derivative
is linear in U they're going to be some
polynomials and X and I can define a
Hankel matrix on what turns out to be
the case is that this if I plug in a
year that's in the hypervelocity Cardon
this thing will be PSD for all X and
conversely if this thing is PSD for all
X and this year has to be like this so
this is this is kind of the central
construction that will produce for us
somehow a family of non-negative
polynomials where I can that are exactly
kind of described by the hyperbola
current corresponding to my hyperbolic
point and I want to point out that I've
presented this in a particular way here
disclosed relatively self-contained to
to define things this way there's a
completely equivalent version of this
story in terms of baizhu shion's where
you're think about interlacing the fact
that this polynomial interlaces this
polynomial if and only if u is in the
hypervelocity cone which as a result
that's in a paper mario coumarin and
cynthia and daniel and these are really
equivalent in the sense that there's a
polynomial congruence transformation
that relates the position of these
things to this
really kind of the same thing just
reading a different basis I wanna say
it's also these results are very very
related to results of Mario Daniel and
Cynthia where so I have a very similar
characterization on the slight
additional assumption on P where you
have you in the high velocity current if
and only if the wronskian of these two
polynomials is non negative which is
really one that one of the diagonal
entries of the Beijing so these ideas
are really all kind of the same thing so
let's do an example because that's a
little bit abstract let's look at the
determinant to restricted to symmetric
matrices and the direction of
high-publicity being the identity
direction so in this case the
eigenvalues the hyperbolic eigenvalues
adjusted the eigenvalues of this
symmetric matrix okay and if you if you
build this object okay it was something
where it turns out to be its IJ entry of
this Hankel matrix is my matrix to this
power okay
x by u my direction and i take the trace
so let's see kind of observe the results
in this setting so if you as PSD so the
hypervelocity cohen here is the positive
semi-definite curtain so if you is in
the high velocity code then you can
factor this thing okay write the IJ
entry is this trace of something times
something transpose so I get a nice
polynomial factorization of this matrix
so it's certainly PSD for all X's like
plug in if u is not PSD then it's not
difficult ok I'm not going to tell you
it's likely how to do it to to be either
explicitly constructed Y to plug into
this PSD matrix okay so that if you do y
transpose you evaluate at x equals U and
you have you in here you get something
you in fact the smallest eigen value of
U which is negative
okay this Y is really the coefficients
of a polynomial that interpolates the
eigenvalues of you that's one on the
smallest eigenvalue of you and zero and
all the other ones so that's really
where this wine comes it's actually this
may be hopes you believe this results in
this concrete case and in fact once you
prove this concrete case you can in fact
use it to prove the the result okay
and I claim this via the help in video
here on that I mentioned a bit later but
many people know this result and the
reason that's true is that if you fix
you when you fix X and you fix identity
the statement is really only about UX
and identity this positivity statement
here all this construction I think about
fixed UX and identity and E that's all
it matters and so I can restrict to a
three dimensional slice and ask this
question of when is this thing positive
on the three dimensional size one way to
establish
all right so what we've now seen or one
way to view what we've just done is a
way to construct a family of
non-negative polynomials associated with
a hyperbola hyperbolic polynomial in a
direction of hypervelocity basically two
pieces of data we used to define I'm
just going to use some notation so that
we can forget about all this stuff and
just think about this object that is you
know some object that's a polynomial in
x and y so I'm just turning this into a
scalar thing to make life better simpler
and it's linear in U it has the property
that this thing is globally non-negative
as a polynomial in x and y if and only
if u is in the hyperbola see you can
also think about really what I'm doing
is producing a you know a convex cone of
non negative polynomials that's really
linearly isomorphic to the hyperbola
grannie a copy of I have a velocity cone
in in non negative components it's a
section of a kind of metaphor all right
so this is a nice construction but
what's kind of very convenient about
this is that the sort of no constraints
here is a globally non negative
polynomials and so I can produce more
non negative polynomials by composing
with polynomial Maps first and that
might seem like a crazy thing to do but
it's really what we do with sum of
squares right we start with non-negative
quadratic forms we compose with some
other women math or whatever and we get
a much bigger family of normal
so I think that's the precedent for
doing what I'm about to do next okay the
slope to introduce this bigger machine
to produce non- following wheels all
right so now there's more data to
specify which is okay maybe good maybe
not good okay but I'm gonna have I'm
gonna need a hyperbolic polynomial with
respect to some direction fix those two
I'm gonna fix so I'm gonna think about
producing polynomials in M variables now
some new space I'm gonna fix a map that
goes from M to RN and another point I'm
a polynomial map from RM to I D to D as
degree and his number of variables but
I'm going to essentially just composing
my two slots with those maps and again
these will all be non-negative
polynomials if you isn't a hypervelocity
code so I'm gonna give this a name just
for them to have a name for the talk and
yeah I'll say that if I can write my
polynomial Q in this form okay for some
fixed p/e
f and G so lots of data to specify or I
could say that Q has a hyperbolic
certificate the morning that
non-negativity and again this produces
for me a nice convex set of non-negative
polynomials okay and this is now this
set of polynomials is now a projection
of the hyperbola
it's a linear projection of a high
publicity coin because if you sort of
were to look at the coefficients of this
polynomial and some basis they would all
be linear functions of you this
expression is still linear in you linear
projection of liability so what's the
other night very nice thing is that if
you give me a polynomial cube and I go
and specify the data for this thing I
can try to search for a description in
this formed by solving a hyperbolic
programming problem because these are
you know if I had this constraint the Q
equals this thing in terms of these this
is giving me a find constraints relating
say the coefficients of here to you in
my form of
sort of intersection of a hyperbole City
coordinates of half our interest rates
so when you say you can search all these
so you're searching which parameters be
used to fix then you're searching over
FNG know P e F and G are figures they're
all fixed you have to specify a lot of
stuff before you start here which is
when the search is over you so I guess P
and E define this family upon a meals
here F and G allow me for example to
change the degree or possibly I might
have a hyperbolic polynomial in I might
have this may not have not many
variables I may want to use I have a
block polynomial with lots more
variables and then restricted to a
subspace using these F n gs so it's very
I mean I don't understand very well what
I can do with these
what happens is the coefficients and you
depend polynomially of the coefficients
of F and G so you F and G should not
know about you but if I fix you one
right I look at the coefficient of U 1
it's linear and you one there's one
coefficient this will be a polynomial in
the coefficients of F and G right can
you say one more time run coefficients
of is linearly depends on you right yep
and coefficients of the UI are
polynomials in the coefficients of f ng
yes and they the linear relations among
these give you the projection of the
hypervelocity
so a regular maintenance program is a
sister I mean these cute for instance
the self juice can you make choices
exaggeratedly embody another om
I guess on the next slide we'll see an
example where you can yep but yeah do it
I don't know in general what how to
choose things have new problems
so maybe no the next slide for the next
next slide so what I want to now move
towards is trying to understand a bit
about how these relate to sums of
squares giving you a way to produce lots
of non-negative polynomials if these
polynomials are all sums of squares it's
probably not very interesting let's at
least see how these are related to some
of the squares in a few different ways
okay so let me just remind you about
something squares I've referred to them
a few times but perhaps not everybody
seen this so if I've got a polynomial Q
and I can write it as a sum of squares
of all the polynomials then I'll call it
a sum of squares it's easy definition
and then evidently my polynomial Q will
be non-negative and we can search you
know if you give me a polynomial Q of
some degree to D even degree I can
search for a sum of squares description
of Q by solving a semi definite
optimization ok so how does that go or
what you do is you build some big long
vector consisting of all the monomials
and these multiple variables they're up
to degree D and then it turns out that
you're a sum of squares if and only if
there exists a positive semi definite
matrix Q here big here so that this
polynomial identity holds so just like
on the previous slide I've got an
expression on the right-hand side it's
linear and cute if Q is in some nice
convex cone then I get non negative
objects I find constraints relating the
coefficients are cute little cute and
the entrance of
similar kind of structure but very much
a semi definite programming and the PSD
so the first thing you're going to
notice is that hyperbolic certificates
if I choose the data these many things
learn to choose if I choose them
carefully I can recapture sums of
squares the choice is quite natural
except for a tiny little slightly weird
thing that I need to do let's have a
look at this so just reminding from the
previous slide so I'm gonna start with a
I'm gonna think about you know all
things that I say sums of squares of
degree 2d okay I'm gonna try to capture
all that collection of things using the
data from this hyperbolic certificates
how do I choose things so I'm gonna
choose P my polynomial to be determinant
of the size actually one larger than the
size here needs to be identity okay
all right the hyperbole hypervelocity
card I'm going to be working with will
be a PSD code and now the other two
pieces of data I need to specify yeah
some polynomial that when P is
determinant should produce symmetric
matrices and some polynomial here that
should produce vectors to go on either
side of the quadratic form so what I'm
gonna do is choose this polynomial F
that produces symmetric matrices okay
and so this this is a small zero this is
a very big zero okay so this is wrong
here that's wrong in that direction it's
the big and then I'm just gonna take my
other polynomial just to pull out one of
the entries it's very simple the key
thing is that if you take the square of
this matrix
the square of this matrix you get the
moment vector times its transpose in
this bottom big ball that's making this
construction work so if you really plug
in these choices what ends up happening
and this pulls out the second diagonal
entry of my ankle matrix which is really
just the trace of this slot squared
times this okay so I've got the trace of
this slot squared times this matrix
which produces for me my sum of squares
I'm not expecting you to sort of see the
details of why that works I'm just
trying to sort of say that you know I
can capture exactly I mean really I
would solve the same semi definite
programming problem choose these data
correctly you will get that family and
that is a family of certificates that's
nicely orthogonal invariants
so of course so it's nice that we can
capture sums of squares but again we
would like to do more than get sums of
squares on a bit construction okay and
so I'm just going to use the definition
for some shorthand so I'm going to say
that a polynomial P is SOS hyperbolic
with respect to a direction if all of
the polynomials I get this way when this
parameter U is my velocity cone are
actually some distance they should be
non-negative but if they're always sums
of squares let's call it SOS hyperbolic
and the question I want to ask is for
which numbers of variables in degrees D
are their hyperbolic polynomials that
are not sums of squares so this is not
it's a hyperbolic polynomials that are
not a service hyperbolic so where my
construction gives me new certificates
of non-negativity that are not captured
by something squares that's the question
I'm going to be interested in I don't
know if this property depends on e the
whole construction does depend on e and
so that's what
all right so let's start with some bad
news okay
depending on your viewpoint is good news
but my for my viewpoint today it's bad
news and that is that there are some
situations where all the things all the
non negative polynomials you've produced
this way will be solved with squares so
one sufficient condition for us to
happen is that if a power of P has a
definite determinant or representation
then P is a service hyperbolic what is
definite determinant of representation
it's a description of P as the
determinant of some expression that's
linear and ex symmetric matrix of the
linearity X that's the determinant or
putt and there's one more piece but
there needs to be a point X that you can
plug in a point you can plug in so this
thing is positive definite so this is
kind of okay so the question is is how
does is it's all about how does this
relate to the generalized Lex conjecture
so in the generalized Lex conjecture
I mean we know and also see an example
later in the talk we know what
polynomials that which no power has a
definite determinant of representation
that for which the high-publicity kind
of spectra he drools a Mario for example
has an exact an example of one of these
we'll see this example so they kind of
these are much stronger requirements
than what the generalized Lex conjecture
denominator sums of squares for certain
okay so that's this is the statement and
this kind of you know there's a result
like this in terms of testing
hypervelocity if you have if you look at
this meat matrix based test for a
publicity that will be a matrix sum of
squares and also sort of the wronskian
version of this Cynthia's paper so
there's really a mild generalization
avoid sickness it's really the same okay
so what does this tell us
I mean based on things we know about
hyperbolic polynomials that have for
which powers have definite in terminal
representations it tells us that if you
start with a hyperbolic polynomial in
three variables from its construction
you'll always produce some of those
squares well you can give a much simpler
direct argument for this also if you
take hyperbolic quadratics these are
always s so as hyperbolic again you
could use the definite determinantal
representation result or give a really
quite easy direct argument it's non-
quadratic forms or something squares is
really be essentially the result and a
result that I learned from mario coma
and i did not know about these very nice
result so there's a results of a result
that says that if you look at a
hyperbolic cubic in four variables the
the square of this thing though this has
a hermitian definite determinant of
representation or it's square has a
symmetric it's a little definitely tell
me about representation this tells us
that hyperbolic cubics in four variables
or ways
okay so what about some other situations
okay so it turns out that if you have
degree for the great list for a number
of variables at least four there's
examples we have now have examples of
polynomials would have known as so as
hyperbolic and okay in the degree three
case and not quite so satisfying so I
have an example of degree three and
forty three variables okay that's not a
cereth hyperbolic and of course we would
like an example in five variables this
is a problem for everyone to work on if
you're interested okay and so really how
does this work you we're gonna I'm going
to show you
minimal examples and then there's
methods to kind of increase the degree
increase the number of variables and
preserve this property of being not as
there is like working example I'm going
to just briefly mention this one that's
a well-known example it's this what we
often call the specialized about much
polynomial you get this by taking the
basis generating polynomial of the bomb
wash may trade and restricting to a four
dimensional subspace okay this is
concrete quartic turns out to be
hyperbolic I mean stables or hyperbolic
with respect to any point in the non
negative orphaned in the positive or
think but in particular type of Baalak
with respect to this choice of you make
this choice of you for whatever reason
you'll get sure that this particular
concrete polynomial it should be
non-negative is not as long as weights I
just want to point out there's a a
really nice construction of non negative
cortex and and higher degree non the
hyperbolic cortex and a higher degree
hyperbolic Camille's Judah Amenia and
Brandon really this is the first case of
[Music]
they really come from taking taking the
same graphs for any graph you can
produce some kind of hyperbolic quartic
sorry does a set up for you for which
you know this point are no fine I saw as
hyperbolic is a convex cone is that
Congress yep how long they said yes the
third of you for which this is yeah this
will give you I mean this is I think
this this was the idea the core idea I
think in
in the paper of Sinclair and Daniel and
Mario was to go in that direction was to
say think about when is this SOS this
gives me something that might be the
high-publicity card or it might be a we
like fishing you know one of the other
week it's hard to think up here about
which way better in approximation why
interested in going the other way and
saying let's imagine I can solve I've
avoid programs reliably and well which
more or less can do what can we use its
for yes yeah okay so let's see I mean in
excess will have degree it's not even by
homogeneous as written here always has
degree 2 and the wise and that has a
component in X of degree
six for two and the way I'm sitting up
here because of the but if I just looked
at a particular combination I would it's
in homogenius annexin-v is quadratic in
the Y one way I can make it sort of not
much more nice and homogeneous is to put
Y as degree six to D minus two so I'm
going to spend a little bit of time the
last few minutes of the talk talking
about cubics okay because this is where
during neuro as much and they're also
nice so let's talk about hyperbolic
cubics and and show you the example I
have of a non SOS hyperbolic cubic it
also say a couple of other things about
how to bollocks okay so the first thing
is you can't see this but okay I mean
it's gonna be easier for us to think
about the hypervelocity test for cubics
in terms of this test based on the
discriminant of this depressed cubic so
effectively for a long time if I look at
a cubic with no quadratic term and I
choose these coefficients to make things
look nice and this is going to have real
roots if and only if very simple
inequality holds on the coefficients and
you can recover this from the fatty
multivariate technology but it's easier
to think about this for now
if particular this is gonna suggest for
me to focus on cubics in a very nice
form okay I'm gonna be interested in
looking at cubics in in n plus 1
variables okay and the direction of
high-publicity being just the first
coordinate direction of this form where
the kind of quadratic coefficient is
just the sum of the squares and then all
the interesting action that comes in
there in the last coefficient that has
low in the coefficient that doesn't
involve X not focus on pubic service
forms you can choose whatever cubic form
you like him in variables to plug in
here
so the first observation is very simple
based on the previous slide okay is it
if you look at cubics of this form then
they're going to be hyperbolic with
respect to the first direction if and
only if I mean this you know quality
holds on the right which is just saying
that the square of your cubic something
of degree 6 is less than or equal to the
cube of the sum of squares for all X in
RN I told you directly or if you want to
reinterpret it genius way that if you
look at the maximum value of this last
coefficient last part of the point I
mean all over the spear there should be
at most one if it's at most one this
thing of all I could respect to that
direction otherwise it won't be a
particular one thing this tells us is a
bit of a side note but it kind of comes
out in the wash it I don't think we knew
this before but it's hard to decide
whether a cubic cos hyperbolic on that
respect another in fact I mean shown by
an asteroid but it really the really
heavy lifting of this result goes back
much earlier to most convince girls a
slightly different context that if you
take a graphic you can define a cubic
polynomial out of the graphs what I'm
gonna have is variables corresponding to
the vertices and variables corresponding
to the edges okay number of edges plus
number of vertices variables I'm just
going to sum over the edges X I times XJ
times y IJ this gives me nice cubic ok
it turns out that the maximum of this
cubic curve of the sphere is some fairly
simple expression involving the size of
the largest clique in the graph
and so if you kind of slightly rewrite
this in this context of hyperbolic
polynomials okay I can define this
family of polynomials okay with a
parameter K an integer so that this
polynomial is hyperbolic with respect to
the first direction if and only if the
size of the maximum clique in the graph
suggests not easy to check
high-publicity in this kind of any
hardness sense a side note let's go back
to our question about SRS hypervelocity
sorry so we've seen that from for cubics
in this particular form a hyperbolic
with respect to the first coordinate
direction if and only if this sec stick
is globally non-negative and it turns
out that if you kind of work through the
work through things and sort of massage
the definition a little bit that if P is
SOS hyperbolic with respect to the first
coordinate direction then this thing
should actually be a sum of squares so
this is in fact the determinant and that
henkle matrix and sort of the hand
combat this hanko matrix is matrix sum
of squares which is really what my
condition is and it's determinant will
be a sum of squares so this is so if I
want to produce an example of a cubic
that's what is the rest hyperbolic one
thing way I could try to do that is to
try to construct a cubic Q for which
this thing has a lot of summer squeeze
so the result in the previous slide
suggests we should be able to find these
things okay and so the question is
really how simple can I make such a
construction so I'm gonna use a
construction that's in the same flavor
so I'm gonna take a graph produce I have
a bollock polynomial chosen these
coefficients so that this thing is
so the maximum value of I mean when I
rewrite when I I guess if I ride this
with a 2 and a 9 over 2 so the maximum
value or the sphere is exactly 1 so
chosing these coefficients based on the
size of lodges cannot be exact I do not
know
it's I think more closely related to
these SRS hierarchy for positivity or
for for the net hierarchy that that's
really when it's construction comes from
your thesis a okay so so I guess so this
is the simplest example I could come up
with
so the graph is this icosahedron graphs
ago sort of one skeleton bike I'll say
he drove it's got 12 vertices 30 edges
12 plus 30 plus 1 is 43 and so that's
where the 43 comes from and I say it has
20 maximum cliques so 20 triangles
because this is kind of one of the
reasons why it's difficult for this
non-negative polynomial to be a sum of
squares so I haven't gone through this
but the places where this Q on the end
here achieves its maximum achieves the
maximum one these are in fact places
where the corresponding hyperbolic
certificates have non negativity all
have to vanish so these polynomials are
constructor hyperbolic certificates that
come from here as long as you don't
compose well the maps all must vanish on
a bunch of points I mean sort of signed
indicators of where these
excellent clicks so if siblings absence
has to have a lot of zeroes in the kind
of events too many zeroes to be a sum of
squares way to find smaller examples
will be considered to construct cubics
on the sphere but have a lot of if you
like absolutely like in vectors if you
like that whose maximum eigen vectors a
lot of them should be the right way to
construct and so one just quick comment
is that as a corollary remember that if
I had a if I have a power of my
hyperbolic polynomial had a definite
determinant of representation there now
is this the rest hyperbolic so it's a
corollary that gives me a cubic for
which no power has a definite
determinate or representation and don't
think we had an example of this before
nice thing that came out on the
Washington okay and of course just to
restate the conjecture you know I guess
the conjecture is that there should be
an example with five variables the 43
comes from one plus 12 plus 13
oh just a one slide of reflection ray V
and then we'll wrap up
so these hyperbolic certificates are you
know a little bit if there's one thing
that's a bit unsatisfying about them as
certificates of non negativity and that
is that this proof of non negativity
relies on a proof of hypervelocity and
we're seeing that okay it's not
necessarily gonna be your you may not
have a nice short proof of hypervelocity
this is suddenly different from SOS if I
give you an SOS certificate there's no
other thing you have to prove apart from
believing that squares are non-negative
it's one sort of thing to reflect on I
think the other thing is that we've
discussed this already there's okay
there's lots of choices in this
construction and all right I don't know
what good choices are in general I think
one of the good things is does then
possibly a chance to tailor these
constructions to a particular problem
class but I think you know at the moment
there's way too many choices and I don't
know where to start I think some of
these are you can view these as features
or bugs they're doing a rich one they
are at this point so we've seen as sort
of tractable sufficient conditions for
polynomial non negativity that we can
search for by solving hyperbolic
optimization problems we're starting a
bit this question of when do I get
things that are not SOS hyperbolic and
so you get a chance of sort of having
new certificates of non-negativity that
are not obviously captured by some
degree so I've seen that certain
situations where all certificates you
get is errors hyperbolic and then it
seems that in larger degrees and larger
number of variables at least we can find
hyperbolic polynomials that will produce
for our certificates that are not some
disgrace we've seen on the way that it's
going to be hard to decide how the
velocity of cubics and any explicit
example of a cubic nerd power which has
a definite determinant of work
one thing I think you know the boy
programming workshop one thing I think
we've lacked so far have been sort of
ways to produce natural hyperbolic
programs to play with to try to see if
you know they do although it work better
than all the things and I hope this is a
possible step towards kind of having a
more generic machine to produce
hyperbolic programs like the sum of
squares machine that produces semi
definite programs that I think has you
know contributed a lot to the some of
your programming just if you're
interested there's a pre pin on the
archive into this wonderful talks we'll
move right away to the question and
discussion session we're going to do
this by boarding groups now okay so
we're gonna have a slightly different
format we're gonna I'm gonna ask you for
question by boarding group so if you are
a PhD student that means you are here
but you do not have a PhD yet anybody
have a question invite the PhD students
to ask the question for the speaker
Jonathan well you must have a question
do you remember generate this polynomial
from some graph I guess maybe a question
could be something like does that mean
that maybe you could think of graphs as
certificates for positivity is there
some more general thing you can say
there
I mean I don't nor is the shortest
answer to that question but I think
perhaps what's nice about being able to
construct these hyperbolic polynomials
that have kind of combinatorial
structure is that potentially then the
certificates you get inherit some of
this combinatorial structure like where
they should vanish you know it somehow
relates to this graph and maybe that I
mean speculating very wildly if you were
much much cleverer than I am you might
be able to use this kind of you might be
able to then somehow Taylor you'll have
two bullet point I me off to some
combinatorial problem that you're trying
to solve I'm sure some undergrads are
also invited to a summation I see okay
anybody else ragged students Jess Isabel
anybody have a question okay so the
second boarding group would be postdocs
so you're a post-op if you do not have a
faculty position like you're not going
to drive somewhere in on people from
Toyota I may be included so if you are
oh do you have a question for the
speaker I can call on people yes you
have these pair of these polynomials FNG
I would say probably not thinking about
the analogy with sum of squares so
choosing I mean choosing the sub space
of polynomials you want to take sums of
squares from is kind of the game we play
when we for example try to come up with
project inspector heat or descriptions
of convex sets and I think this is
still pretty much an auth so I think
it's very much like doing PST
vectorization of non-negative matrices
like that seems to be a much harder
problem than kind of once you've fixed
your each of those functions you're
using then sort of combining them in a
nice combo okay so here with encourage
other postdocs ask questions Catarina
clear okay last call I guess the senior
so now general boarding so I guess
if we don't allow these composition
where a lot of things then I'm een an
example I wonder about a tannery non-
ternary cortex like Motzkin okay at
least you know if I start with a three
variable I can thought polynomial I'm
not gonna be able to capture that
there's a free variable hyperbolic
polynomial will be SOS hyperbole but I
could potentially use like employ
polynomial with many more variables or
with more variables you know look at the
family of things that produces in there
restrict to a subspace so I mean so I
saw it's kind of when you allow this
more flexibility it's to me much less
clear why is it possible I have not I
mean I then have to sure I guess I don't
have an explicit one where I know that
there isn't a way to choose P and F ng
and always start some crazy I mean it's
possible
so in terms of the number of vitamins
reviews things in many violet words from
somehow your original data which is more
number of particles the original data
being your choices that you make I'm
thinking kind of like the way that you
would use comes right
you have family some inequalities right
now when you really want something is
they know to extend those inequalities
to don't doubt your number of particles
of the premiership classically you
cannot do this in other than
combinatorially but in here and can you
actually search some power I don't know
I've only really thought about the other
direction of starting with a bigger
thing the number of variables you're
looking for and then I do think I didn't
so I guess the the conjecture is that
one exists in five variables and that
kind of there's a bit I mean the reason
for this conjecture is that the special
case of hyperbolic
cubics in four variables one reason you
that might not be so crazy about it that
happens is because of the special case
of
but Turner aquatics quartic forms being
a son book squares and this kind of non
negative ten or aquatics all beings on
the squares at least if you so for
example if you look at the basin and you
look at the the one one entry of the
Babycham which should be a non negative
polynomial in that case once you sort of
do things correctly you will get a
Turner Aquatic form it's not negative
and it's not at all obvious and I don't
know how to extend that to give a direct
proof in that case but this is sort of
some evidence that there's somehow
something special happens in that case
hey these are not unrelated and the
dimension counts when you look at things
correctly seem to be the same so because
that's that's the kind of reason
variables SOS where you didn't get a
hyper boy's certificate or an upper
bound
can you get a sequence of grass with a
bound we could clarify the gap
operations that preserve
like certify them you look at all--if
which of these like preserve SOS yes
yeah
knowing great detail sir for example I
mean multiplying things if their
birthday so much hyperbolic than the
result yes
essentially the beyond that situation
I'm not sure I mean I think this for
example one thing I didn't save it I
should say that if your SMS hyperbolic
one implication of that is that your
high publicity coin as a projected
speakers you drop one of these
operations we don't know what they do to
that the more interesting operationally
derivative question material in the
univariate case which would be saying
that
and what the is how is this classic yes
I don't know the exactly the criterion
you're referring to in that description
but yeah sir yeah they talk about are in
the break exactly one last question
okay if not then we'll thank dams again
[Applause]